let's return now to the strike action
going on today workers at the uk's
largest telecom provider are walking out
today in a dispute over pay well the
general secretary of the communication
workers union dave ward joins me now
from the picket line so dave ward why
are you striking
yeah good morning anna um well our
members this is the first strike in over
35 years
across the bt group
and the reason that we're striking today
is because the guy who runs
bt
uh philip jansen and the bald are
ripping off the workers and ripping off
customers at the same time and so what
we're seeing at the moment is the
company
posting profits last year of 1.3 billion
pounds
they've just posted profits in the first
quarter of this year of 400 million
pounds and they've imposed a pay deal
this year on the workforce that is
simply insufficient to deal with the
situation with a cost of living crisis
and you know i'm going to say this today
that there needs to be some sort of
inquiry into the actions
of of these balls that are ripping off
the whole of society at the moment and
our members are not going to put up with
it anymore
well yes and the bt boss himself though
says he thinks what workers have been
offered is fair and affordable he says
it compares really well with any other
company and he said he's sad
disappointed that the strikes are going
ahead today
he says that workers at bt have been
offered the biggest pay rise for 20
years
well that's not true
and the reality is is our members never
had a pay rise the year before they had
a one-off bonus
and this year uh what they've offered is
is insufficient
i mean this is against the background as
well when i say that they are ripping
off people and our members are feeling
disgusted at the actions of the ceo and
the ball
these guys he got a 32
increase
and i just don't think that this is
acceptable anymore today i think every
single one of your viewers
will understand that this level of
inequality in the way that workers are
being treated versus the companies
themselves they gave 750 million pounds
to shareholders
before they then imposed an inferior pay
deal for workers this can't continue
people are not going to put up with it
but meanwhile
around the issue of strikes there's been
a lot of news hasn't there the labour
leader kirstala sacked his shadow
transport minister sam terry terry who
joined the picket lines um
hadn't he this week um
he said it was for doing unauthorized
interviews with the likes of us here at
sky news and was making policy up on the
hoof
what do you make of labour's handling of
the strikes
i mean look that's a matter for for kia
stammer um but i have to say that um
from where i'm sitting it looks to me
like labour want to win an election uh
without any principles and i think
people will see through that over time
um i think our own members will feel
really you know unhappy about the way
that labour are dealing with these
things in these moments you know when
people are under so much pressure you
have to come forward with policies you
have to be prepared to support working
people and if labor don't do that i
think trade unions and community
organizations will fill that vacuum
to stand up for working people and
that's what we're also
talking about you know we're also
talking about other forms alongside this
particular dispute and we're talking
about you know forms of collective
action uh later on in the summer that
all workers can participate in um and
we're talking to other trade union
leaders about that as part of a campaign
for a new deal for workers separate to
this current dispute
we will
expand on that a little bit i mean
labour's former shadow chancellor john
mcdonnell uh said that he would support
a general strike where different
industries coordinate action is that
something that you would look to do
well you know i mean the general strike
took place in 1926. our focus is on our
members primarily
um and that is you know where that will
remain but let me say that at the same
time i do think that working people have
been let down
across the political parties at the
moment i think they have to come
together in a different format
i would support a new social movement
led by trade unions community
organizations to stand up for working
people and we are talking
to other trade union leaders and the tuc
about forms of collective action that we
could all take so you know that that
will probably start in the next few
weeks
what would it look like
well i think that's for us to have those
discussions uh i think there'll be a
moment probably where we'll hold a press
conference and we'll be happy to talk to
you about what that looks like but i
think it's about making the government
uh
act to support working people on the
cost of living crisis and all of the
things that are associated with that but
also to act against these type of
business leaders you know you can't
carry on here
um letting these type of people
live almost in a parallel galaxy let
alone a parallel universe
and
treat their workers the way they are and
they are ripping off customers these
guys announced yesterday on top of 400
million in the first quarter profit on
top of the 1.3 billion that they are
going to put prices up which will amount
to 23
price increase in 12 months
uh i don't think anybody will accept
that and i would urge the government to
do an inquiry into the way that bt are
running this company
okay and and of course the boss would
say he's just looking after the company
and and its future which is in the
interests of the workers at dave we
appreciate your time thanks very much
indeed for talking to us this morning
thank you